Cole Hauser is known to many as tough guy
Rip Wheeler on Paramount's "Yellowstone."
He's the ranch foreman, who just so happens
to be the right-hand man to family patriarch
John Dutton.
He's fiercely loyal both in terms of his work
on the ranch as well as his relationship with
John's daughter, Beth.
The two have maintained an intriguing yet
often heartwarming relationship throughout
the show's run, and it's only gotten more
intense going into Season 4.
Beth's gone through a lot over the course
of the series.
She survived a horrific attack against her
life, coming out of the situation relatively
unharmed.
After escaping by the skin of her teeth, she's
continued to give back to her community, which
includes preventing a kid from falling into
homelessness, all while Rip has been there
by her side.
That doesn't mean things have been easy for
the couple.
They've gone through the wringer more than
a few times over the course of the show, and
luckily, the two actors have each other as
support when they're acting out emotional
scenes.
According to Hauser, it's been an immense
pleasure working alongside someone as talented
as Kelly Reilly all these years.
"What do you want?"
"To make a scene.
You ready to watch that happen?"
Even if you've only watched a couple of episodes
of "Yellowstone," you know it's an intense
show.
It's undoubtedly hard work for the actors
once in a while to embody these characters,
so it helps when they get along with one another.
That's the case with Hauser and Reilly, with
the former having nothing but praise for his
co-star.
The actor sat down for an interview with CinemaBlend
to discuss acting alongside one of the finest
television actresses working today.
As he put it,
"In Season 4, there's an obstacle or obstacles
that they have to face, and it was wonderful
doing it with Kelly.
She's one of my favorite actresses I've ever
worked with, and working with her on this
relationship has just been so much fun."
Of course, it helps when the material is good
enough to stand on its own.
In the same interview, Hauser praised the
show's creator, Taylor Sheridan, and the team
behind the scenes for crafting complex characters
who have continued to grow over the years,
saying,
"I mean, you know, once again, I think Taylor
[Sheridan] did just a fantastic job of putting
these two kids together, and seeing how they
can grow, and how their hearts can be more
open.
How they can navigate different waters together,
and find even a stronger bond through those
waters."
Just like their characters, it's nothing but
love between these two.
Hauser's not the only one who's enjoyed his
time with Reilly over the years.
Beth Dutton has a more tumultuous relationship
with her adopted brother, Jamie, played by
Wes Bentley, but Bentley still enjoys every
scene he gets to do with Reilly.
In a similar interview with CinemaBlend, he
mentioned,
"[Kelly Reilly] is one of the sweetest people
and sweetest actors.
She has to go so far to get to Beth.
She does an amazing job."
Kelly Reilly may be intimidating as Beth,
but it's clear she knows how to turn on the
charm when the cameras stop rolling.
It's good to hear that the two don't have
the same kind of relationship off of the set
that their characters have.
It likely wouldn't result in the same kind
of dynamic because, as Bentley goes on to
state, there needs to be respect and admiration
toward your fellow actors to get a worthwhile
performance, even if the characters are supposed
to hate one another.
That's what Bentley goes on to mention in
the interview:
"It's hard because if you truly don't like
each other, it almost has the opposite effect.
There's a lack of chemistry, you know?
You kind of have to have some connection to
really go for the anger."
And "anger" is definitely an apt word to describe
the relationship between Beth and Jamie.
It's a good thing these actors all like each
other off-set because things are about to
get messy over on the Dutton Ranch.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Yellowstone
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.